[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no we don't want a YouTube in here
[Music]
Trash Talk we're back drock I'm glad you
didn't miss the alarm another one after
that one I woke up you were involved in
one after that one talk episode seven I
think drock is back did not oversleep
Eric I'm not sure if that's true
and the whole episode was me saying I'm
glad you're awake yeah okay fair enough
that is ring a bell it's been a little
while okay 11 months since we've done a
last trash talk I'm highly motivated for
this trash talk because one I really
want to dig in because I'm very
motivated because with all of my content
I'm obsessed with the concept of how
does this work and I wanted to bring
value and I want it to you know either
be very clouds or very dirt this week's
crash talk is at the wine library's
hometown of Springfield New Jersey
[Music]
foreign
cities in my life I spent 20 years in
that city building up my father's liquor
store and I bought one of my best garage
sale items ever in one of the first
Springfield town wide sales in like 2001
maybe 20 years ago they had a gorgeous
like complete
1974 1977 Fisher Price Little People
Sesame Street set I think they wanted
15. they didn't get it
I think I got it for five slipped that
hard for like 97 bucks wait a minute
what are you doing
it's all goes to the same place no it
does not they sure don't I think it
would be fine really
I feel pretty good I feel pretty
confident too because I drove this for
seven years reverse commute from New
York City to Springfield New Jersey and
I'm telling you you're taking me to the
[ __ ] Jersey Shore and some Bon Jovi
[ __ ] and we're [ __ ] going to
Springfield look at this we've been
[ __ ] they Rock we've been flying to
Orlando right now and [ __ ] it's like
five no brother I'm telling you I'm
telling you there's no turn there that's
another seven miles before there's
anywhere you can go because that's
called Newark Airport you know it
but it cost is 30. I'm taking over now
I'm ways go straight
[Music]
away no left
left
switch
[Music]
I don't understand that this doesn't
light up yeah it doesn't light up but
it's right there not three weird it's
pretty straightforward
oh baby
strategies to dominate
hello how are you how much are the
stuffed animals oh like 50 cents to a
dollar depending on you know these like
a bug they're like there's just nothing
but money I got some stuffed animals
stuffed animals always Crush little baby
shark and a little I have no idea but I
just want to teach people that for 50
cents you take a rider on a stuffed
animal
gotta go to the tags I'm getting old I
can't see [ __ ] you have any idea what
this is but you know what's cool you can
tweet it out and be like who is this
from what yep
[Music]
the least I'm gonna pick up a bunch of
stuffed animals today is I really need
everybody to understand how big of an
Arbitrage mugs and stuffed animals are
oh wait a minute though
there it is it looks terrible
and I don't like these dudes age these
guys
they're a problem and I'm gonna grab
this waffle maker not because I want it
but because I want them to be upset that
they didn't grab it because they were
debating it that's gonna freak them out
[Music]
I got it
just wasting [ __ ] time here
those kids are doing damage I respect
their hustle you found something
how much is it 27 how much does she have
it listed for
all right they're cool everybody was
just here for that is that right okay so
I'll come back take your chances right
thank you so much all right did
something that I don't usually do I
didn't negotiate I was about to go for
10. but I'm a little rusty I just just
pulled out my cash like a [ __ ] losing
player in garage sale life
but if lose right these nine could be
good so we got here is
Buick 2004. man this is already almost
20 years it's crazy we're gonna win that
game I saw the Chryslers someone opened
50 bucks
completed yeah
and
we got to really go through it but like
the potential is there I don't want to
like overstate it for trash talk but
we're gonna we're gonna do it
hi
you are currently being recorded good
what's the story of my life hello hi hi
good how much is the Yankees rug
uh I'll give it to you for 15 because it
was like a hundred dollars it's really
cool yeah it's handmade is that right
yeah
it's really cool I grew up a Yankee fan
but I've been raising my son a Mets fan
so I'm torn between this decision Isn't
that cool that's cool would you do 10
for it
sure just to get rid of it yeah
it's too big to still have around thank
you so much oh I agree oh it's heavy
it's real yeah this is not a [ __ ]
rug Lou it's a real ass rug thank you
it's a perfect example ten dollars like
let's be honest you list this on
Etsy for like a buck 50 and you're
rolling on a buck 40.
this truck I told you you can't start a
garage sale with a garage sale already
in the truck I mean that rug alone
peace for the day I think somebody in
the office should put up the rug for
like a buck 50 and we'll donate the
money to charity there's no way that rug
doesn't sell for a buck 50. I see some
action here that I'm interested in
double house action yeah oh
I see things are happening already yeah
and I don't know like
I'm gonna attack here thank you hi hi
good morning
how much are Beanie Babies
I didn't even bring mine I have the
entire collection no you do not tell me
honestly what do you think I should be
charging for them I think you should go
to eBay look them up one by one take
care
oh there's a big sale up there
sensing real opportunity up here
have the best Sarah stay well I'm going
to stay optimistic
have a great day these prices are
terrible these prices are absurd
everybody decided they're eBay
I ruined it there it is oh man this
one's terrible God damn it 10
to no no no no no no no
we're getting cold thank God for that
damn Yankee rug
sad I need to get hot I need a big score
out the gate to get me going
I'm gonna stay optimistic
I'm optimistic like an otter
see that's a professional garage sale
sign I already know that it's bad
because the sign's too professional that
means they do it often and just
everything's overpriced and been worked
through the professional signs
they're the wackest
good morning good morning how are you
I'm good you good
do you have any video games
I have a question though for you yeah I
have
um wheat we I have the entire system
yeah the weight yep what would that be
worth I think you should look on eBay
but the last time I looked I think
they're like 40 30 50 depending on
certain variables look it up on Ebay
completed items is that something you'd
be interested in I would take a look
okay it's not here okay got it well I
live down in Barnegat well we're gonna
go to Barnegat then all right now we're
just giving out free tips to the
competition
I mean Not only was there nothing there
but I basically just told her how to run
her business and how to sell her Wii and
for how much and on what platform we are
really rusty point of the show is to do
it for all 8 million on the other side
not the one person in front of us we we
have to like attack this show was
created for the people that said cool
Gary I don't have 25k I got 25 bucks I'm
like okay [ __ ] trash talk and
when you're trash talking you don't tell
them where to sell their [ __ ] for how
much they say three bucks you say no you
say a dollar that's [ __ ] trash talk
oh Jesus Christ
I think I saw something
is it a garage sale or the biggest dog
I've ever seen in my life that dog is
insane
buddy
this
but not these games
you don't have RPG games bro
yeah
what's up brother nice to meet you how
are you big fan thanks man as everybody
is thank you how are you great I don't
know if we have anything that's uh award
to you I know my son you can take if you
want how much is he
um 100 bucks would you take 30. yeah
yeah
brother yeah I wish you guys the best
best
hello how are you doing good yes
you got slapped he's got good intuition
he knows who you are drock take care
penny
look the bottom line is it's not been
the hottest garage sale day but the
content's off the charts drock just got
hit by a kid
videos thank you brother he's all over
YouTube and everything what's your name
hey Ed nice to meet you
good scene
I'm just doing a sitcom now
[Music]
how much is the parrot dog
I don't do that the parent knows the
parrots Know Who You Are
that power knows who I am yeah
no it's for you waiting oh got it thank
you I finished guys hello how are you
I'm well do you have video games sorry
no thank you or something YouTube sorry
no there's nothing to be sorry about
have the best day take care
[Music]
and tick tock
Frozen
what are we doing with the camera
YouTube
no we don't want a YouTube in here
[Music]
ice cold
all right I'm telling you right now
drock
I feel like a late strike right there
whoa this actually looks good wait a
minute because she's gonna check that
out a little bit things things might
have changed
hello hello
oh my God
[Music]
how much is this
um five dollars
two three four five six
seven eight nine
there's nine of them I would do it for
30.
all right how much are these you do 35
for this
let's do it
all right everybody we're gonna just
drive it a little bit up this is like
could be the last thing we find so
all right let's go first here or what is
this Darth Maul what year there we go
good job drock
2013. three bucks a piece
Chima eglore 15 bucks 12 bucks we paid
three bucks a piece trash talk baby
Trash Talk how you doing good go do your
thing
Trash Talk crew great day with my boys
get in here drock now you know we were
recording or not oh are we yeah we are
okay good I actually love this episode
to me a day where I had to cut it short
and yet still between the rug and the
Star Wars and Lego toys the stuffed
animals you're still talking about 150
200 bucks on a Saturday where we were
ice cold in Springfield that to me is
just like perfect that's like the whole
point of this damn show let's use this
episode to eliminate the excuses yes you
have to pay taxes you have to pay taxes
for everything yes there's gas fees
there's cost of doing business and
everything charge them shipping let's
change our mindset let's go get it hope
you enjoyed it hope this is entertaining
we'll do it again soon see ya
[Music]
of course
wow
come on
I said baby
I know you're on the road